This is something
we have in common.
At what age -- he's 14 now --
at what age did he comprehend
what it was you
that did for a living?
-I don't know exactly.
But I'll give you an example --
two examples that I think
illustrate perhaps nothing.
[ Laughter ]
You know when you're driving in
New York City,
like, coming down
the West Side Highway,
and there is only two ways in
and two ways out
of New York City.
And you hear
one of these crazy motorcycles.
It just...
[ Imitates motorcycle ]
And traffic is stalled.
But you see a guy coming.
And he's weaving in and out
of traffic.
If he's going 100,
he's going 120.
So we're stuck in traffic,
and here comes this guy.
And on his back,
he has a big, like,
semi-metallic instrument case,
you know,
one of those great big things
you put
a stringed instrument in.
And he is going 120
with this thing on his back.
And my son screamed,
"Get out of my way!
I'm late for the cello lesson!"
[ Laughter ]
I thought that was pretty good.
-That's really good.
-So now we're farther down the
road and we're stuck in traffic.
And it's hot as hell.
And I roll down the window
and Harry says to me,
"Dad, roll up the window."
And I said, "Harry, it's
screaming hot in here.
Why do I have to
roll up the window?"
And my son says to me,
"Someone might see you."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, there you go.
So does that answer
your question?
Yeah, I felt pretty good.
-That's really --
-Yeah, that's right.
[ Applause ]
-How does --
Does your son -- Does your son
have an opinion on the beard?
-You know, that's interesting.
I forget that
I have the damn beard.
[ Laughter ]
And I'm surprised that no one
has said to me, "Hey, dumbass."
[ Laughter ]
I was up skiing in the Catskills
one day last winter.
And driving out, there is a ski
store that says goggles sale.
And so I stopped
and I thought, "Whoa!"
-Yeah.
-You know, if you don't stop for
a goggle sale,
there is not much left in you.
[ Laughter ]
So I go in,
and I see a guy in there.
And I said, "I guess
this is your busy time of year."
And he says, "Why?"
And I said, "Well, goggle sale."
[ Laughter ]
And he said,
"What can I do for you?"
He was not in any mood.
And I said, "I'm here to buy
a pair of pants for my son."
He said,
"Oh, they're all over there.
So I find a pair of pants.
And he says,
"Okay, is your son here?"
And I just looked around and I
said, "No, he's not here."
I said, "Stay in the car.
I'm going in there
to buy you pants."
[ Laughter ]
I said -- He said, "Well, you
know, there is no refunds."
The guy says to me, and I said,
"Don't worry about it.
If they don't fit,
I'll just bring it right back
and get a refund."
[ Laughter ]
He's not laughing at
any of this.
[ Laughter ]
So, now I pay --
It's like 120 bucks.
So, I got a wad of 20s and I
start counting out the 20s.
The guy --
I've never seen this before --
the guy picks up each 20, looks
at it and then makes a mark
and then picks it up and looks
at it and makes a mark.
And he gets about halfway
through,
and I said to him, "I'm sorry.
What are you doing?"
He said, "I'm just doing my job.
I have to check and see
if they're counterfeit."
And I said, "Really?
Do I look like the kind of guy
that would come up here
and start passing
counterfeit --"
And then I realized,
"Oh, yeah, I do."
[ Laughter ]
I forgot.